okay I'm a medical student
and I have to study for many hours during the day
and this is one of my most unconventional tips
for people that have trouble focusing when they're studying
and I'm I'm gonna warn you
it is very unconventional and honestly
a little strange
so it doesn't work for everyone
but basically
I started to notice how on TikTok
there were certain sounds that I just like
couldn't get out of my head
and it would just like
repeat over and over again
and I started to think like
hey I could use this to my advantage
so I found songs that kind of scratch that itch in my brain
and I just play that song over and over again
like that song on repeat while I'm studying
over and over again
like usually I do a different song every day
but sometimes the song bleeds into the next day
but it just like
becomes background noise
and it just gets you in the zone
like just try it before you think I'm crazy
because I've had some friends try it
and they love it